volt boy here def definitely not marry
this is vault boy with a game spot news
update fallout 4 has gone gold the wait
is almost over Bethesda made the
announcement today on Twitter October
23rd the bombs have fallen fallout 4 is
complete all 27 version an image of the
retail version was attached to the tweet
even though the base is completed this
doesn't mean that the pheasant is
finished with fallout 4 as expected the
developers will be working on content
updates and expansion the first of which
will launch in early 2016 in addition
the developer is still hard at work on
PC modding tools which won't be
available until after the game launches
this isn't the only fallout news to come
out today but says de clarified that the
pc version does require a partial seen
download fallout 4 hits shelves on
november 10th for xbox one ps4 and pc
fun fact october 23rd 2077 is the day
the bombs fell in the fallout universe
it's the actual day that's a great war
started and ended for everything fall
out you go to gamespot com